we're going to the waters of social
justice are just they're impossible to
solve
yeah it really inserts like Jim Norton
said it's just like someone is backing
up and throwing down landmines and
you're just hoping that you don't hit a
new one you don't know which new word is
going to trip it up you don't know which
new value but here to hopefully clear
things up for us is social justice where
you're Skylar and thanks to the
technology afforded to us and the budget
thanks to mug club club we actually have
a cryogenically frozen social justice
warrior from 2012 yeah so that's right
so we have - Dexter unfrozen 2012 social
justice our quarterly 12 here with us
with Skylar current social justice where
the year is 2017 gentlemen can you hear
me are you with us a lot of clearance
glad to be here great you bet and Dexter
really quickly um how have you been
handling the the filling process oh very
well very well feel invigorated well
that's wonderful to hear
yes thank you and you let me take a
moment to thank you Steven for the
opportunity to take part of this very
important and critical discussion I
think if I may the main takeaway of
social justice is that even we are all
the same we are all okay whoa whoa whoa
saying that we're all the same okay
don't you see that is maybe that
problematic problematic equality is what
we we all strive for equality and unity
with everyone it doesn't matter if
you're black or white or if you're out
well it's people of color rope coming
out sorry it's people of color wow that
just sounds like another way of saying
colored people and that's racist okay no
it's people period of period color
that's what they want okay you don't get
to label them you probably know that if
you checked your white privilege I don't
know what that means but I was sure to
use the right term going toward the
point they're on when white and the
color people come together and strive
for unity we have so much common ground
we can just live as colorblind ah no let
me know sorry colorblindness just blinds
us to her own privilege okay it's that
kind of archaic thinking it is exactly
why now people of color are required to
have people of color
we save spaces on our college campuses
people of color only that's how a lot
like segregation color movie before the
term safe spaces see it allows people
just to the color gender mental
affliction or worldly to separate
themselves into their own space
exclusively for like-minded people were
no views of criticism or opposing
viewpoints are allowed safe spaces
well exactly I have always been on the
forefront of fighting systemic systemic
sort of institutional racism and
equality patriarchy for instance isn't a
medieval practice they need to be
abolished men to do everything that
women can do in vice versa ah what was
that I'm sorry was that no no I can hear
you and unfortunately our audience can -
did you really just perpetuate the
gender binary did I yes exactly you said
that women can do anything a man can do
of course
what about trans obviously what about
pants I'm sorry pansexual love cars I
how can we forget the LGBTQ qaa IP sorry
oh gosh I should notice is what happens
when you deep saw a caveman trigger
warning Flintstone alert Bam Bam Bam Bam
I don't even know what uh LGBTQA IP you
Syst privilege [ __ ] that's lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer sometimes
questioning asexual allies and pan what
I'm hard about I get again we all have
room to grow Dexter clearly your
intersectionality lies somewhere between
ignorant and full-fledged bigot
I'm willing to march on King's black you
[ __ ] Nazi I don't even know how to it
okay Dexter you don't listen I'm really
glad okay you're unfrozen that's super
cool
all right but call me when you're woke
why not come on give me a dictionary
maybe a google source like this video
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button it's a kid sinesses circle now it
used to be a square which most buttons
aren't squares what sits on a phone
there's square buttons on phones what
most buttons are circles you understand
what I'm talking about or watch the
recommended video which is popping up in
a box or subscribe at lateral clutter
calm flashmob join the mud clips you can
get the daily show and that means that
you are not beholden to the YouTube
censoring overlords
let's be honest you like being there
where you are under their thumb power
bottom you